wir haben sie zitiert herr müller
eingangs mit dem satz sie möchten
kindern und jugendlichen einen
impfangebot machen wir haben heute auch
noch mal bei ihm nachgefragt 50 prozent
der 60 bis 69 jährigen sind noch nicht
erst geimpft in deutschland und bei den
70 bis 79 jährigen sind es 45 prozent
noch nicht erst die impfung ist es gut
zu diesen vielen menschen die noch keine
erstimpfung gesehen haben jetzt noch 6,9
bedürftige kinder und jugendliche zu
packen 6,9 millionen
aber es ist ja ein prozess und man muss
ja damit auch anfangen
auch die kinder haben in den usa haben
in den letzten monaten auch sehr viel
verzichtet die kinder und jugendlichen
und wir haben viele ältere oder
erkrankte wird vorerkrankungen die ja
schon sich um einen termin bemüht haben
und demnächst auch dran sind oder von
den mobilen f teams betreut werden die
kinder und jugendlichen die sich jetzt
demnächst um einen termin bewerben
können und bemühen können sind ja nicht
sofort dran mit der impfung auch dort
dauert ist ja wieder einige wochen bis
sie ihren termin haben und ich finde es
richtig auch diese perspektive zu
eröffnen
auch die kinder und jugendlichen müssen
die chance haben auch ins nächste
schuljahr vielleicht mit ein stück mehr
sicherheit zu starten für die familien
ist das wichtig und irgendwann muss man
damit beginnen
wir wollen aber mehr menschen 6,9
millionen menschen mehr impfen mit nicht
mehr impfstoff den wir haben
das heißt es gibt eine irrsinnige
erwartungshaltung die wir noch viel
weniger befriedigen können das hat heute
eine große rolle gespielt und es gab da
auch große verärgerung bei den
ministerpräsidenten weil in den letzten
wochen der eindruck erweckt wurde als ob
wir mit zusätzlichen impfstoff eine
extra kampagne für die kinder und
jugendlichen machen können und heute in
der beratung ist das deutlich geworden
dass das bundesgesundheitsministerium
dazu viel versprochen hat es gibt nicht
mehr impfstoff und das was frau
katzenstein erlebt es eben das was wir
alle jahr erleben dass wir immer noch
einen mangel verwalten in dieser
situation und insofern war heute dieser
klarheit auch wichtig wir können die
kinder und jugendlichen jetzt wenn die
priorität fällt können wir nun mit rein
nehmen und ihnen angebote machen aber es
wird nicht mehr impfstoff geben und
insofern auch keine eigene kampagne und
diese klarstellung musste heute erfolgen
weil sonst werden die hoffnung geweckt
die nicht zum schluss nicht gehalten
werden können auch nicht von der
bundesebene
ich frage sie gleich noch wie das beim
gesundheitsminister angekommen ist und
bei dem rest ihrer kollegen begrüße an
der stelle ganz herzlich in der runde
ranga yogeshwar wissenschaftsjournalist
physiker ranga die angst vor dem virus
hat man das gefühl nimmt bei den
menschen ab auch weil sie sehen dass die
instanzen sinken dass die zahlen besser
sind
es ist wieder möglich sich die eine oder
andere freiheit zu gönnen es schwindet
aber damit natürlich auch vorsichtig
findet respekt vielleicht auch vor dem
virus ist es das was die biologen
beschreiben mit dem sozialen ende einer
pandemie dass die menschen einfach
irgendwann kein bock mehr haben und sie
für beendet erklären
ja das können wir eigentlich emotional
alle ganz gut nachvollziehen also es ist
so dass wir jetzt über ein jahr
einschränkungen haben geburtstag in
einer gewissen einsamkeit feiern müssen
familien können sich nicht treffen
hochzeiten fallen in der form als großes
fest aus also das nervt irgendwann das
kann man gut nachvollziehen
aber der entscheidende punkt dabei ist
ich glaube es ist irgendwann so ein
prozess wo menschen anfangen zu
verdrängen also wo sie einfach nicht
mehr bereit sind diesen ausnahmezustand
noch fortzusetzen und dann kommt eben
ein verdrängungsprozess der mit film zu
tun hat also auf der einen seite das
risiko auf der anderen seite wagt man
dinge
das geht bis hin zur gefahr die man
irgendwann zwar im hinterkopf hat aber
dennoch einfach leben möchte und ich
glaube das ist ein relativ natürlicher
prozess aber ist natürlich nicht sehr
klug im kontext dieser pandemie
wo es jetzt darum geht wirklich auch
immer noch risikogruppen zu schützen
also wir müssen uns klar machen
über 80 prozent der menschen die
momentan auf intensivstationen liegen
sind über 55 das sind nicht die kinder
und jugendlichen das sind die älteren
und es wird auch heute immer noch
gestorben also das ist nicht irgendein
luxus das ist mehr aber wie gesagt diese
phase der verdrängung setzt ein bei uns
auch übrigens in anderen ländern finden
sie ist klug ranga dass den kindern und
jugendlichen dieses angebot jetzt aber
gemacht wird dass sie sich einreihen
sollen dass diese priorisierung fällt
also ich finde es persönlich nicht klug
aus zwei gründen das eine ist und das
ist ja schon angeklungen wir haben ganz
wichtige gruppen immer noch nicht
geimpft also konkretes beispiel jeder
zweite im alter eher von 60 plus ist
noch nicht geimpft worden
und da müsste man weitermachen und die
gefahr ist ein fehler der oft genug in
der pandemie gemacht wurde nämlich eine
erwartungshaltung auszusprechen die dann
wenn es konkret wird nicht erfüllt wird
das haben wir im letzten jahr ende
letzten jahres gesehen mit dem lockdown
wo uns etwas versprochen wurde was dann
nicht einhaltbar das haben auch alle
wissenschaftler gesagt und ähnlich ist
es jetzt also im grunde genommen junge
menschen oder familien zu mobilisieren
vor dem hintergrund dass wir tatsächlich
noch nicht genug impfstoff haben auch
für die wichtigen risikogruppen die nun
mal älter sind ist ehrlich gesagt nicht
sehr klug aber wir haben ein wahljahr
das ist noch ein gutes stichwort aber
wir marschieren jetzt noch mal tief in
die wissenschaft zu helga rübsamen chef
nämlich einen herzlichen guten abend
nach düsseldorf zurück samen chef sie
sind biologen und forschen seit
jahrzehnten für verschiedene
pharmakonzerne und können uns bei der
beantwortung der frage helfen was sagen
sie
als wissenschaftlerin eigentlich dazu
dass jetzt auch kindern und jugendlichen
dieses angebot gemacht werden gemacht
wird vielleicht um tatsächlich auch dann
ein wenig schneller die herdenimmunität
zu erreichen fragezeichen das ist genau
das stichwort würde ich sagen weil sie
die frage welches ziel wollen wir
erreichen wollen wir menschen die
gefährdet sind als kinder und
jugendliche so schnell wie möglich
impfen oder wollen wir in deutschland
die die epidemie so schnell wie möglich
in griff bekommen und aus dem kinder und
jugendliche sich genauso infizieren
können dass sie es genauso weiter geben
können wie erwachsene und nach dem
kinder und jugendliche eine immobile
gruppe sind die mit vielen menschen aus
anderen haushalten schon
notwendigerweise in der schule etc
zusammen kommt glaube ich dass das für
die beherrschung der epidemie ein
durchaus interessante strategie wäre und
sein abgesehen davon dass jeder glaube
ich sich darüber im klaren ist dass die
kinder wieder in die schule müssen und
dass das natürlich auch dann zu ihrem
schutz dient bin krank werden können die
auch krank werden können die kinder auch
es ist allerdings ein wesentlich
geringerer prozentsatz der bei den
kindern und jugendlichen dazu nennen ist
wenn sie sich jetzt aber vorstellen frau
katzenstein das und was in ihrer praxis
eigentlich losgeht wenn zu den vielen
menschen die da ohnehin schon stehen
jetzt also auch noch familien mit ihren
kindern und jugendlichen kommen
was bedeutet das werden sie diesen
ansturm jetzt schon herr oder ist das
eigentlich auch schon nicht mehr
abgesehen von dem ansturm also es gibt
natürlich individuelle impfentscheidung
'nen die
getroffen werden müssen wenn wir zum
beispiel selber erkrankt sind also ein
down kind ist eventuell gefährdeter wie
ein gesundes kind
und da muss das mit den eltern
besprochen werden ob das kind geimpft
wird
aber ich glaube man überschätzt weit die
impfbereitschaft der eltern also ich das
ist eine neue technologie ein neuer
impfstoff ein protein impfstoff steht
relativ nah vor der tür das ist eine
herkömmliche methode der impfung
das wird 2022 wahrscheinlich zugelassen
also ich schätze das jetzt nicht so ein
dass alle ihre kleineren kinder impfen
lassen möchten also die erkrankung ist
ja wirklich mild ich habe selber einen
zwölfjährigen den habe ich kurz vorher
noch gefragt sagte wieso ich werde
wahrscheinlich nicht krank also dass man
muss ja die eltern und die kinder auch
noch ins boot holen und ich bin da nicht
so überzeugt dass das alle machen
möchten frau rief seinen chef wie groß
ist ihre sorge eigentlich überhaupt vor
diesem ende der pandemie das besprochen
wird
am ende gibt es wie die wissenschaftler
die sagen es gibt überhaupt gar kein
ende
die kanzlerin sagt wir sind da noch
lange nicht angekommen gibt es ein
medizinisches ende der pandemie also ich
würde erstmal so sagen pandemie bedeutet
ja eine weltumspannende epidemie und
weltumspannend wird man das sicherlich
nicht in einem jahr im griff haben man
kann aber beispiele dafür jetzt schon
heran führen dass es einzelnen ländern
gelingen kann
sehr gute zahlen zu erreichen denken sie
an israel da sind die meisten menschen
60 prozent erstmals geimpft und auf 60%
zweites mal geimpft die haben jetzt noch
aktuell ich habe mir die zahlen fallen
rausgesucht 346 infizierte im land seit
tagen keine todesfälle mehr und die neue
infektion können sie an der hand
abzählen also das heißt wenn diese
situation auch ein bisschen länger
anhält kann man vielleicht sogar
ausgehen davon ausgehen dass das virus
aus dem land weg ist natürlich wird die
gefahr bestehen dass von außerhalb
wieder virus eingeschleppt und deswegen
wird die pandemie noch lange nicht
beherrscht sein also ich gehe auch davon
aus dass man wesentlich längeren atem
braucht aber israel zeigt auch wenn man
nur konsequent ist und die 60 prozent
erst und zwar in form erreicht deswegen
halte ich auch dänemark führt zu früh da
schon zu öffnen das noch in der menge
erreichen kann
und wenn sie nochmal nach großbritannien
gucken die haben auch 60% erstimpfung
aber nur schon 30 prozent zweitimpfung
die haben zehnmal soviel aktuelle
infektionen noch auf die köpfe
bevölkerung berechnet wie israel
und da ist ja auch die indische variante
angekommen und macht schon 3400
infektionen aus da könnte eine welle
gerade wieder hochgehen
das haben wir heute in den agenturen
gelesen man muss vielleicht auch noch
mal sagen dass israel nun auch politisch
in einer besonderen situation ist und
vielleicht mit wenigen ländern in der
welt vergleichbar
großbritannien ist ein interessantes
stichwort britische mutante hatten wir
erst mit sorge betrachtet nun die
indische die sich in großbritannien
offensichtlich durchgesetzt hat fürchten
sie also durchaus die möglichkeit einer
zweiten dritten vierten welle dritten
und vierten will
es wird diskutiert dass die jetzige
indische variante noch mal 50 prozent
infektiöser sei
wie gesagt im moment ist für sich
schätzen dass du zehn prozent in
großbritannien damit infiziert sind srk
robert-koch-institut bei uns sagt 2
prozent der neuinfektionen sind indische
variante
man kann nicht ausschließen dass sie
sich weiter durchsetzt aber es gibt auch
eine gute nachricht zumindest gehen
davon im moment alle davon aus dass die
impfstoffe zumindest noch vor schwerer
krankheit die dieselvariante ausgelöst
werden kann schützen und das ist auf
jeden fall schon
trotz aller problematik eine gute
nachricht weil wir nicht sofort darüber
reden müssen auch eine dritte impfung zu
brauchen oder wenigstens eine
auffrischung oder rechnen sie im grunde
auch damit also es gibt ja eine studie
inzwischen die hat biontech weiser
gemacht die haben ein drittes mal
geimpft und haben entschuldigen
die haben gezeigt dass wenn ich ein
erstes mal mit astrazeneca geimpft werde
und dann ein zweites mal mit bier und
denkt dass ich dann eine super gute
immunantwort krieg also wenn ich diese
tolle immunantwort habe brauche ich
vielleicht kleine ecke eine dritte
impfung wenn sie zweimal piontek nehmen
dann sind sie nach einem monat bei 95
prozent schutz vor der krankheit
und nach sechs monaten bei 91,3 immer
noch ein sehr hoher schutz
ob man jetzt in einem jahr nach impfen
muss dass das kann auch noch niemand
sagen aber im moment ist der schutz noch
gut wie fürsorge ranga yogeshwar hebt er
schon die hand dann vielleicht wenn eine
retoure ich wollte fragen wie viel sorge
müssen wir vor den menschen haben die
sich gar nicht impfen lassen wollen also
da natürlich viele sorge aber ich knüpfe
noch einmal an er das wasser gar rübsam
gesagt hat wir haben eine situation in
deutschland die moment wie in einigen
sehr reichen industrieländern also
israel wurde genannt großbritannien die
usa wo wir lokal inzwischen die
instanzen runter bringen wo wir so ein
bisschen das gefühl haben das schlimmste
ist durch aber wir müssen uns wirklich
klar machen pandemie heißt wir müssen
weltweit betrachten wenn sich den
heutigen tag anschauen allein in indien
über 200.000 neuinfektionen und man sich
klar machen es sind genau diese ärmeren
länder in denen die impfungen nicht so
schnell vorangehen
die natürlich zu einem nährboden von
neuen varianten werden also diese
variance of konzern wie sie heißen die
entstehen in südafrika in brasilien oder
eben jetzt in indien und da gibt es
nicht nur eine variante es gibt
inzwischen mehrere typen und wenn wir da
eben nicht aufpassen dann werden wir
irgendwann eine neue variante haben die
so mutiert ist dass die impfstoffe die
wir moment nutzen vielleicht eben nicht
so wirksam sind und dann gehts das spiel
von vorne los das heißt wir werden
alternativ los etwas schaffen müssen und
das ist die gesamte welt zu unterstützen
bei der impfung denn nur wenn das virus
weltweit eben nicht mehr weiter kassiert
werden auch die möglichkeiten dramatisch
reduziert dass es neue varianten gibt
also nur bei uns zu gucken ist einfach
zu kurz geschockt das ist ein super
interessante hinweis den ich jetzt nicht
ganz fitte schieben möchte aber ich will
ihnen einmal nochmal ein stückchen
weiter in der sendung schieben weil wir
uns doch zunächst noch mal auf
deutschland und europa konzentrieren
wollen und uns natürlich auch fragen ob
wir gut beraten sind in dieser situation
hier im land noch mal ganz kurz da hin
zurück eine priorisierung aufzuheben
herr müller sie müssen uns noch mal
erklären ob man gut beraten jetzt sagen
kann alle bemühen sich um diese wenigen
wir haben ja auch in deutschland noch
nicht genug fürs lösel um diese wenigen
nicht ausreichenden vakzine und lassen
jetzt da immer mehr menschen hinein und
sich mit den ellenbogen den impftermin
erkaufen
es werden ja von woche zu woche auch
mehr impfstoffe die uns zur verfügung
stehen und wir haben ja auch das system
verändert das war ja zu beginn der
pandemie eine große diskussion wann
können die hausärzte endlich mit dazu
kommen wir werden jetzt in diesen tagen
ja die betriebsärzte eigene bundesländer
machen ist ja schon die betriebsärzte
mit in das system bekommen und
zusätzlich mit dem mehr an impfstoffen
schaffen wir natürlich auch mehr wir
hatten jetzt mehrere tage hintereinander
wo wir eine million impfungen pro tag
vornehmen konnten und dass man in so
einer situation auch sagt dass die sorge
von herrn logisch ja berechtigt also
dass jetzt die älteren natürlich weiter
geimpft werden müssen das ist doch klar
das darf ich doch nicht aufgeben ich
muss an der stelle weitermachen aber
dass ich mit mehr möglichkeiten auch
eine größere gruppe von menschen
ansprechen und ihnen die chance eröffne
eine impfung jetzt oder in wenigen
wochen in anspruch zu nehmen
ich glaube dass es dann auch überfällig
wie ihr verrückt samen chef hatte noch
einmal bezug genommen auf dänemark und
gesagt wenn die über 50-jährigen
erstmalig geimpft sind dann ist ihr das
zu früh um alle maßnahmen und alle ver
und gebote einzustellen machen wir uns
aber wenn das machen sie nicht da ist er
flink mit der antwort
wenn aber alle über 50 jährigen zweimal
geimpft werden dann hätten wir herr
müller hätten sie dann auch das gefühl
dass das größte risiko das zentrale
risiko bearbeitet und beendet ist das
heißt das gefühl die menschen haben dann
ganz wissen sie haben ganz
selbstverständliche rechte die sie dann
natürlich auch in anspruch fordern
richtige zweifach geimpft mit der
entsprechenden jahr zeit danach bis der
volle impfschutz dann sich auch
entfaltet hat die haben
selbstverständliche rechte im
öffentlichen leben und insofern kommen
wir jetzt schon zur formulierung wo wir
sagen in einem restaurant dürfen fünf
menschen sitzen plus zweifach geimpft
weil die eben schon diese rechte auch in
anspruch nehmen können oder sich sogar
einklagen
also insofern muss man sehen es ist eine
gratwanderung ich finde die diskussion
um die bekämpfung der weltweiten
pandemie völlig richtig und wir müssen
glaube ich das eine tun ohne das
angriffs wohl und das andere lassen wir
darauf noch kommen aber erst gucken wir
noch mal ganz konkret nach neukölln von
der welt nach neukölln wissen sie jetzt
eigentlich frau katzenstein wen sie mit
welchem impfstoff als nächstes als
erstes zweites oder drittes impfen wenn
diese priorisierung aufgehoben wird
ich war von vornherein gegen eine
zentralistische ansatz der priorisierung
priorisieren sollte man auf lokaler
ebene also das heißt der einzelne arzt
muss praktisch mit seinen patienten im
gespräch priorisieren und dann ist auch
verständnis aber den patienten also ich
hab auch zum beispiel schon eine volle
impfsprechstunde gehabt und dann kommt
eine 80-jährige den beruflichen
patienten an und sagt darf ich
verschieben
ich habe eine 80-jährige und kein
problem also das problem was ich
kritisiert habe ist das erst mal so eine
ganz starke priorisierung gemacht wurde
alles nur über die impfzentren die
impfzentren konnten die wirklichen
problemen fälle häufig gar nicht
erfassen und die mobilen teams für die
alten ja dass versuche aber dass ein
impfzentrum zum beispiel also das sind
ja komplexe systeme also ich habe jetzt
zum beispiel eine familie gehabt ein
schwerstbehinderter vater und beatmungs
richtiges kind nicht erfasst durch das
impfzentrum und ich kann die noch viele
solche fälle erzählen von den
obdachlosen da bin ich in
da sind höchstens 20 wohl die umsetzungs
weise von diesen organisationen die
obdachlose betreuen
also wir sind wirklich ich glaube von
vornherein wäre es besser gewesen wenn
hausärzte priorisieren hätten dürfen mit
ihren patienten dann wären wir
wahrscheinlich schon schritt weiter
aber jetzt die impfzentren finde ich
trotzdem super mit den massenimpfungen
losgehen also wenn wir jetzt wirklich
den ansturm haben dann können ja die
jungen internetaffinen leute gerne ins
im zentrum aber diese komplexeren fehde
sind sicherlich besser wenn den
hausarztpraxen es ist auch menschen die
noch gewisse ängste oder skepsis haben
sie habe auch ich kenne diesen glaube
ich wir brauchen auch die waren wirklich
tolle zeit verschleudert würde ich sagen
indem man 40 tausend hausärzte
ausgeschlossen hat fast alle jedermann
die klage sicher die hausärzte das ist
alles viel zu viel ist also erst wollten
sie dass sie irgendwie die impfzentren
dass sie genauso priorisiert werden wie
eben die impfzentren und jetzt sagen sie
dass ihnen das alles zuviel ist was ich
weiß jetzt nicht also ich persönlich
auch nicht wie ich fühle mich ehrlich
gesagt viel besser weil ich meinen
patienten jetzt was anbieten kann wer
also vorher habe ich zeit verschwendet
um einzelne patienten die ganz dringend
geimpft wurden
da gab es keine möglichkeit die
irgendwie ins system reinzubringen es
war wirklich ein ding der unmöglichkeit
ich denke die meisten ärzte impfen
eigentlich gerne ob man nur noch impfen
will das ist ein bisschen in frage und
sie hätten es eben gerne sehr sehr viel
früher das ja nur noch angetan hier auch
schon viel diskutiert blick noch einmal
auf die generationen frau katzenstein
glauben sie dass die solidarität der
älteren tatsächlich auch so weit gehen
zu sagen okay dann verstehe ich die
jungen brauchen biontech dann
akzeptieren wir für die 60 jährigen
astra gibt es solche diskussionen solche
angebote schon von menschen älteren
datums ich finde man muss nicht
irgendwie die menschen gegeneinander
ausspielen also wenn eine 80-jährige
fürchterliche angst vor astrazeneca hat
was sie auch verstehen kann weil die
informationsmöglichkeiten einer
80-jährigen geringer sind und fielen
durch die medien geht eigentlich eben
mit bei uns überhaupt gar keine frage
wenn eine 18-jährige geimpft werden
möchte mit astra und irgendwelche ärzte
dann würde ich sie auch mit bayern
kämpfen also man kann ja hoffen dass wir
bald im impfstoff schwimmen hoffentlich
zumindest habe ich gehört acht impfdosen
pro bundesbürger und bestellt dann fragt
sich wieder was
ich glaube es sind noch 48 ist kanada
und usa hat acht mal und hier haben
glaube ich die vierfache menge mehr
gelaufen und da fragt sich wieder in
einer pandemischen situation ist das
denn das richtige ja dann müssen wir
eigentlich über unsere nationalen
grenzen hinweg
und da sind wir noch und begrüßen vorher
aber unbedingt und live und in farbe
mirko drotschmann bekannt auch als
mister wilson to go ist uns wie es skype
zugeschaltet macht einen erfolgenden
youtube-kanal es geht um gesellschaft um
politik und um wissenschaft sie sind
vater von zwei kindern von zwei töchtern
nämlich eine 1 und einer fünfjährigen
jetzt sagt heute per drop man die
politik sie möchte auch kinder und
jugendliche impfen ist es eine gute idee
in ihren augen ja grundsätzlich schon
aber ist es in meinen augen vor allem
augenwischerei
es ist ja auch schon angeklungen das ist
ziemlich unrealistisch ist dass man als
junger mensch bald einen impftermin
bekommt und ich finde dass man damit von
politischer seite auch ein
generationenkonflikt schürt man sorgt es
für eine situation dass die 80-jährige
sich quasi mit dem 18 jährigen um einen
impftermin ja wie soll man sagen mal
kriegen muss und das sollte natürlich so
nicht sein das bin ich schwierig und vor
allen dingen ist es auch ein weiterer
nackenschlag auf den rücken
aber nach den nackten junger menschen
die zum beispiel zur schule gehen und zu
beginn der pandemie immer wieder gehört
haben ihr seid die treiber der pandemie
dann haben sie gehört wir haben kein
geld für luftfilter dann hier ist es das
erste wasser wieder aufmachen das sind
die schulen und die kindergärten es ist
dann irgendwie auch nicht passiert und
jetzt heißt es ihr bekommt einen
impftermin bis ende august also
theoretisch aber vielleicht auch nicht
also so als würde man sagen in dem raum
hier steht eine große torte die steht
aber schon seit einer halben stunde da
und das sind 50 leute drin also da würde
ich mir ein bisschen mehr ehrlichkeit
wünschen zumal die stiko bisher ja auch
zurückhaltend ist ich frage nicht warum
man die priorisierung jetzt aufhebt und
damit fakten schafft die für ein
generationenkonflikt sorgen werden
herr müller ist natürlich sofort gefragt
hat man viel zu spät auf die jungen
leute guckt auf die kinder und
jugendlichen geguckt und macht man ihnen
jetzt noch mal die frage von vorhin und
eigenes barren verstreut wird im moment
gerade alles miteinander verwischt die
priorisierung ist aufgehoben worden
ganz unabhängig von der debatte um die
kinder oder jugendlichen weil man eben
auch gesagt hat man muss nicht mehr
priorisiert nach bestimmten alters oder
berufsgruppen oder man will es nicht und
deswegen wird ab dem 7 0 6 für alle das
geöffnet wir machen weiter mit den
älteren mit den erkrankten aber die
anderen haben jetzt auch eine chance
parallel dessen stifter es bleibt dabei
dass wir immer noch einmal mehr ohne
mehr im stoff aber die prioritäten
aufhebung hatte erstmal mit kindern und
jugendlichen gar nichts zu tun der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat von sich
aus eine weitere debatte angefangen und
den eindruck erweckt als ob es mit
zusätzlichen impfstoff jetzt eine eigene
impfkampagne für kinder und jugendliche
geben kann das wurde heute aufgeklärt
auch von seiten der ministerpräsidenten
dass das nicht der fall ist
gleichwohl haben wir gesagt wenn wir für
alle anderen öffnen warum dann nicht
auch für die kinder und jugendlichen die
möglichkeit schaffen sich für die
nächsten wochen auch um einen impftermin
zu bemühen insbesondere dann wenn wir
auch mehr impfstoffe bekommen das muss
man schon auseinanderhalten und die
situation an den schulen dass die
bedrückend ist und dass wir auch da
wirklich versucht haben in allen
bundesländern so viel wie möglich auch
darzustellen und zu öffnen und zu
ermöglichen für die kinder ist doch
unstrittig aber es bleibt doch eine
gratwanderung bisher
ich habe in berlin sie haben es
angesprochen eine 35 inzidenz großartig
in der entsprechenden altersgruppe in
den schulen bei den zehn bis 17 18
jährigen habe ich eine 65
das kann ja auch nicht wegdiskutieren
dass es dort auch gefahren gibt also
heißt dass wir machen der permanent
getestet wird jede tüte testen vielen
natürlich deswegen ist nicht die
intelligenz hoch sondern das wird sie
entdeckten incident sie ist das hier
wird entdeckt und das ist gut dass man
schnell reagieren kann es gibt also
gefahren an der schneller was machen wir
aber eben nicht schwarz-weiß schule auf
schule zu keine angebote sondern in
dieser grad war
darum machen wir so viel möglich wie es
geht mit dem wechsel unterricht mit den
luftfiltern mit maske tragen mit außen
angeboten und und und und ich glaube das
muss man einfach anerkennen dass wir es
schwer haben an dieser stelle mit
schwarz und weiß eine einfache antwort
zu geben sondern dass wir in der
gratwanderung versuchen gerade im kita-
und schulbereich so viel wie möglich zu
ermöglichen ohne die gesundheit zu
gefährden so und jetzt erkläre ich noch
mal was ich sagen wollte ihn nirgendwo
sonst wird so systematisch getestet wie
in den schulen und deshalb finden wir
wahrscheinlich auch mehr incident bei
den kindern und jugendlichen
und vielleicht kann man so auch diesen
diese exponentielle hohe infektion
erklären bei den kindern an den schulen
die interessante frage ist ja was machen
die jetzt eigentlich bis ende august
herr müller also wir können vielleicht
nicht den schülern und jugendlichen
jetzt diese impfungen anbieten darüber
reden wir haben wir alternativen um
schule und studium trotzdem wie möglich
zu machen
wie sehen die aus bis gestern wurde noch
gesagt es ist ganz ganz wichtig dass es
uns gelingt der
bundesgesundheitsminister diese
impfungen anzubieten und jetzt heißt es
plötzlich von der politik es reicht
eigentlich wenn sich alle an die
testungen halten und wir hatten heute
den chef der stiko mit dabei unsere
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und er hat
noch mal ganz deutlich gemacht die das
impfen für kinder und jugendliche kann
ein zusätzlicher schutz sein aber man
kann selbstverständlich in diesem
bereich auch sicheren unterricht
anbieten unabhängig von den impfungen
mit all den anderen regeln natürlich die
auch umgesetzt werden müssen
und man sieht dann eben auch dass es zu
infektionen kommt zur infektion die auch
dramatisch verlaufen können kinder
können auch schwer erkranken können auch
sterben in aller regel aber ist das
risiko deutlich geringer als in anderen
altersgruppen und die stieg geworden und
die stiko hat aus ihrer kompetenz heraus
gesagt da können wir uns politisch ja
gar nicht einmischen wir haben das
fachwissen gar nicht hat die stiko heute
auch noch einmal deutlich gemacht dass
sie glauben dass man eben auch
unabhängig von diesem impfangebot dass
man gut und richtig finden kann oder
auch nicht einen sicheren schulbetrieb
darstellen kann
so wie wir es ja auch in den vergangenen
monaten gemacht wir machen gleich weiter
herr drotschmann wird
sie erstens wenn die kinder schon in dem
alter wären jetzt ihre kinder gerne
impfen wollen
oder sind sie zurückhaltend und sagen es
wäre im grunde viel wichtiger dass die
eltern also sie 35 und ihre frau weiß
ich nicht wie alt sie ist und die lehrer
und erzieher geimpft werden ja zunächst
mal würde ich mir wünschen dass die
besonders gefährdeten menschen alle
geimpft werden und da schließe ich mich
den konsens in der runde auch an das ist
das wichtigste das hat priorität
und wenn es dann die möglichkeit gibt
und es sicher ist dass kinder geimpft
werden können dann wäre ich persönlich
auch dafür aber ich sehe schon auch so
dass eltern zu einer priorisierung
gruppe gehören sollten denn sie haben
kontakt zu menschen nämlich eben zu
ihren kindern die besonders viele andere
menschen treffen in der schule oder im
kindergarten und dafür nicht schon
wichtig wenn es die entsprechende
möglichkeiten gebe und dass mir ehrlich
gesagt bei der diskussion immer auch ein
bisschen zu kurz kommt ist der blick auf
das seelische befinden die seelische
gesundheit die universität das
universitätsklinikum hamburg-eppendorf
unter so zum beispiel der cops die
studie die auswirkungen der pandemie und
der maßnahmen auf die psyche von
jugendlichen und kindern und vier von
fünf der befragten kinder und
jugendlichen bei der letzten studie
fühlen sich durch die korona pandemie
belastet sieben von zehn geben
der gemeldete lebensqualität an das ist
schon sehr alarmierend jugendpsychiater
in ganz deutschland schlagen alarm und
auch bei den studierenden das ist
übrigens nicht anders jeder fünfte
student denkt darüber nach sein studium
vorzeitig zu beenden weil er mit der
situation nicht zurecht kommt das hat
ein team der uni hildesheim leute ich
rausgefunden in der befragung und das
sind schon alles dinge die wir auch im
blick nehmen sollten und auch das macht
was mit einem menschen diese schüler und
studierenden vor katzenstein sind
gegebenenfalls auch in ihrer praxis
würden sie aus ihrer erfahrung sagen wir
müssen unbedingt schulen und
universitäten wieder öffnen auch
unabhängig davon wie hoch jetzt konkret
die infektionszahlen sind weil das
gesellschaftlich nicht mehr moderieren
nicht mehr aus haltbar ist und weil das
risiko ja sinkt durch das weitere
impften der älteren keine leichte frage
ich gebe es zu also ich habe dazu eine
meinung also ich denke ja und wenn
risikopatienten geimpft sind so bald wie
möglich oder risiko nicht patienten aber
menschen
ist das ja auch möglich also mir geht es
eigentlich darum dass man erst mal einen
gewissen respekt den jugendlichen und
kindern gegenüber zeigt was mir manchmal
fehlt auf den straßen
also ich lebe in kreuzberg und auf den
skater plätzen ist zum beispiel viel
polizei unterwegs und dann frage ich
mich warum werden diese jugendlichen die
sich draußen aufhalten und das richtige
tun dann von der polizei belästigt und
mit bußgeldern belegt dass man zumindest
das was möglich ist den jugendlichen
wirklich uneingeschränkt sie waren ja
auch gegen die nächtliche ausgangssperre
wenn ich mich recht erinnere ja warum
sollen jugendliche nicht abends im park
zusammen sitzen das ist das richtige
mario sohle sind im innenbereich arioso
lhe im innenbereich sind gefährlich
draußen ist die gefährlichkeit wirklich
vernachlässigbar
und das ist mir wichtig dass wir eine
art von zivilen leben zurückfinden um
eine gewisse gelassenheit und ich denke
dann wird es den jugendlichen und
kindern auch besser gehen also kinder
wieder spielen lassen betreuung draußen
stattfinden lassen universitäten wieder
öffnen ja dafür bin ich dafür wäre mal
kommen wir noch mal zum impfen
vielleicht lassen wir jetzt wirklich die
stiko ranga yogeshwar ist gleich dran
noch mal zu wort kommen die politik will
eben unbedingt impfen und die stiko
bremst wir hören noch mal in welcher art
und weise und mit welchen begründungen
siehst du
zurück in die schule nach den
sommerferien soll präsenzunterricht
wieder möglich sein
auch deswegen sollen jüngere ab siebter
juni ein impfangebot bekommen kinder und
jugendliche können dann ab dem ende der
priorisierung sich auch um einen
impftermin bemühen
bereits morgen dürfte biontech für
zwölf- bis 15-jährige zugelassen werden
doch die ständige impfkommission bremst
sie hält nicht viel von der vorschnellen
ankündigung der politik wie auch das
glauben denn ich weder auf zuruf des
ministers noch auf zuruf der industrie
und ob es eine generelle impfempfehlung
geben wird das halte ich nicht für sehr
wahrscheinlich
warum das beantwortet eine kinderärztin
so die masse der kinder trägt ja nicht
das risiko schwer an coop 19 zu
erkranken
hier muss wirklich eine große risiko
nutzen abwägung sein welches risiko hat
das kind schwer zu erkranken
und was ist der benefit fürs kind einer
solchen impfung nur um herdenimmunität
zu erreichen sollte man kinder
jedenfalls nicht impfen
also jetzt ist ranga yogeshwar daran es
ist wirklich eine komplizierte situation
erstes gilt es zu vermeiden
alte gegen jüngere aus zu spielen
zweitens gilt ist zu vermeiden die
jüngeren weiter leiden zu lassen
und drittens muss die frage beantworten
wer ist solidarisch mit denen die so
lange solidarisch waren ich glaube
gerade wenn man kinder und jugendliche
betrachtet sieht man zwei wichtige
aspekte und diesen kater angeklungen man
muss sie mal nebeneinander stellen
auf der einen seite geht es um das
risiko der kinder der jugendlichen
selber zu erkranken und da wissen wir
nun seit einem jahr dass die weit
weniger gefährdet sind als die anderen
das zweite ist aber und auch das ist
angeklungen bei frau katzenberg
dass kinder und jugendliche natürlich in
der schule networking haben viele
freunde haben und dadurch und das war
die grosse gefahr in der vergangenheit
zu verteilen des virus werden
und jetzt haben wir im grunde genommen
einfach folgende situation wenn wir
glück haben und irgendwann ein großteil
der älteren menschen geimpft ist dann
kann man sich sogar erlauben dass viele
kinder und jugendliche noch nicht
geimpft sind denn die können das virus
zwar weiter geben aber die eltern werden
damit nicht infiziert oder nicht so
infiziert wie hat sie noch nicht geimpft
waren und ich glaube genau da muss man
ehrlich sein denn was wir im moment
diskutieren ist noch alles auf dem
hintergrund es ist angeklungen von
mangelwirtschaft also noch haben wir zu
wenig impfstoff für die menschen die ihn
haben wollen
aber wir müssen uns etwas klar machen in
vielleicht zwei oder drei monaten wird
sich das ganze umkehren
dann werden wir eine situation haben bei
der wir genügend impfstoff haben aber
bei der es durchaus eine ganze reihe
menschen in unserer bevölkerung gibt die
einfach sagen ich möchte nicht geimpft
werden
und damit ist das große ziel der
herdenimmunität gefährdet und ich bin
eigentlich ein bisschen ja skeptisch
vorschnell in dem moment kinder und
jugendliche zu nutzen um im grunde
genommen die herdenimmunität zu
etablieren das heißt wir werden
diskussionen in zwei drei monaten haben
die ganz anders sind nämlich wo ärzte
skeptiker menschen überzeugen müssen und
sagen müssen okay du hast vielleicht
angst oder so aber lass dich impfen weil
es ist wichtig für dich und vielleicht
auch wichtig für die gesellschaft
interessanter aspekt für rücknahmen chef
hebt die hand und ist sofort dran
also ich bin ja schon dezidiert anderer
meinung ich glaube schon dass die
impfung von ab 12 jährigen durch
klinische studien als sicher und wirksam
belegt ist und dass es auch sinn macht
kinder und jugendliche zu impfen eben um
sie als überträger auszuschließen und
ich sage ja immer wieder
wir sind in einer instabilen situation
wir können jederzeit neue
varianten auch ins land eingeschleppt
bekommen in velbert sind kürzlich 56
infizierte personen in einem hochhaus
aus sieben familien festgestellt worden
da waren auch kinder dabei
also ich denke dass die kinder schon
einen beitrag leisten können
das eben weniger infektionen übertragen
werden und ich halte das auch für
wichtig weil eben nicht die gesamte
bevölkerung zu 100 prozent geimpft
werden kann
ja herr drotschmann gibt auch den finger
ja ich sehe das ähnlich und wir müssen
dann auch ehrlich sein also wenn wir
sagen na ja gut wir lassen jetzt die
kinder und jugendlichen erst mal außen
vor denn die sind ja nicht so starke
pferde dann sprechen wir de facto von
einer durchseuchung das ist ganz klar
wir gehen das risiko ein dass sie sich
reihenweise anstecken infizieren und
dass die unter umständen erkranken und
ja der verlauf mag nicht so schwer sein
aber ich kenne tatsächlich 25 jährige
die seit monaten nicht mehr die treppe
hoch laufen können und das würde ich
jetzt nicht einfach so wegwischen und
sagen na ja gut
die können wir erst mal aus dem blick
verlieren unter 20 jährige das ist ein
punkt wir reden nun jetzt eben mit
diesem neuen beschluss ja von 12 bis 16
jährigen und dann ist jetzt noch mal auf
die stiko zu verweisen die sagt wir
müssen risiko und nutzen abwägen und wir
müssen natürlich auch nebenwirkungen und
risiken dass wir jetzt nochmal meine
frage an frau rübsamen chef bei den
kindern in ein anderes verhältnis setzen
zum nutzen den sie persönlich haben
herr professor mertens sagte so eine
impfung ist kein bonbon das ist ein
medizinischer eingriff und da muss man
sich sicher sein sie sagen er sollte
sich sicher sein der professor mertens
sag mal so es gibt ja diese klinischen
studien die gemacht worden sind und
aufgrund dieser studien sind die
impfstoffe ja auch dann zur zulassung
eingereicht worden für die ab 12
jährigen und mir ist dann kein
gravierendes problem bekannt also als ob
kinder irgendwie schwierigere
impfnebenwirkungen haben als erwachsene
das ist geht jetzt überhaupt nicht
gesehen worden
es geht wahrscheinlich eben nur um die
priorisierung auch nochmal wer das
betonen ich meine auch wenn sie nicht so
häufig schwere verläufe haben sie haben
sie können sie aber bekommen und
sind das junge menschen die die also
völlig aus dem leben gerissen werden und
das kann man eigentlich auch nicht
wollen natürlich bisher alles durch die
durch die mangelsituation bedingt aber
sobald wir können glaubt macht es sehr
viel sehe meinen augen eben auch jüngere
zu impfen
das argument der stiko war ja die kinder
und jugendlichen dürfen jetzt nicht
einfach nur benutzt werden als argument
um diese jeden immunität zu erreichen
zurück samen chef sie machen insgesamt
14 prozent der bevölkerung aus sie wären
eigentlich auch nicht zwingend notwendig
um diese immunität zu erreichen richtig
wie gesagt wenn wir glauben dass die
daten aus israel uns eine antwort geben
da müssen sie 60 prozent der bevölkerung
zweimal geimpft haben
ob dann und kinder dabei sind ein wenig
ist egal wir haben auf jeden fall denke
ich genügend leute die aus gründen nicht
in irgendwelchen gründen nicht geimpft
werden können nicht gut auf den
impfstoff reagieren die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen das ist ja schon
mehrfach angeklungen also warum nicht
die kinder die sich impfen lassen wollen
beziehungsweise deren eltern dazu
stimmen mit ins boot zu nehmen